YUFEI ZHAO: Last time, we
considered the relationship
between pseudo-random graphs
and their eigenvalues.
And the main message is that
the smaller your second largest
eigenvalue is, the more
pseudo-random a graph is.
In particular, we were
looking at this class
of graphs that are d-regular--
they are somewhat easier
to think about.
And there is a
limit to how small
the second largest
eigenvalue can be.
And that was given by
the Alon-Boppana bound.
You should think of d
here as a fixed number--
so here, d is a fixed constant.
Then, as the number of
vertices becomes large,
the second largest eigenvalue
of a d-regular graph cannot be
less than this
quantity over here.
So this is the
limit to how small
this second largest
eigenvalue can be.
And last time, we gave
a proof of this bound
by constructing an
appropriate function that
witnesses this lambda 2.
We also gave a
second proof which
proves a slightly
weaker result, which
is that the second largest
eigenvalue in absolute value
is at least this quantity.
So in spirit, it amounts to
roughly the same result--
although technically,
it's a little bit weaker.
And that one we proved
by counting walks.
And also at the
end of last time,
I remarked that
this number here--
the fundamental
significance of this number
is that it is the
spectral radius
of the infinite d-regular tree.
So that's why this
number is here.
Of course, we proved
some lower bound.
But you can always
ask the question,
is this the best
possible lower bound?
Maybe it's possible to prove
a somewhat higher bound.
And that turns out
not to be the case.
So that's the first
thing that we'll
see today is some discussions--
I won't show you any proofs--
but some discussions on why
this number is best possible.
And this is a very interesting
area of graph theory--
goes under the name
of Ramanujan graphs.
So I'll explain the history
in a second, why they're
called Ramanujan graphs.
Ramanujan did not
study these graphs,
but they are called
them for good reasons.
So by definition, a Ramanujan
graph is a d-regular graph,
such that, if you look at its
eigenvalue of the adjacency
matrix, as above, the second
largest eigenvalue in absolute
value is, at most,
that bound up there--
2 root d minus 1.
So it's the best possible
constant you could put here
so that there still exists
infinitely many d-regular
Ramanujan graphs for fixed d--
and the size of the
graph going to infinity.
And the last time, we also
introduced some terminology.
Let me just repeat that here.
So this is, in other
words, an nd lambda graph,
with lambda at most
2 root d minus 1.
Now, it is not hard to obtain
a single example of a Ramanujan
graph.
So I just want some
graph such that--
or the top eigenvalue is d.
I want the other
ones to be small.
So for example, if you get
this click, it's d-regular.
Here, the top eigenvalue is d.
And if it's not
too hard to compute
that all the other eigenvalues
are equal to exactly minus 1.
So this is an easy computation.
But the point is that I
want to construct graphs--
I want to understand
whether they
are graphs where d is fixed.
So this is somehow
not a good example.
What we really want is fixed
d and n going to infinity.
Large number of vertices.
And the main open conjecture in
this area is that for every d,
there exists infinitely many
Ramanujan d-regular graphs.
So let me tell you
some partial results
and also explain the
history of why they're
called Ramanujan graphs.
So the first paper
where this name
appeared and coined this name--
and I'll explain the
reason in a second--
is this important result of
Lubotzky, Phillips, and Sarnak.
From the late '80s.
So their paper was
titled Ramanujan graphs.
So they proved that
this conjecture is true.
So the conjecture is true for
all d, such that d minus 1
is a prime number.
I should also remark
that the same result
was proved independently by
Margulis at the same time.
Their construction of this graph
is a specific Cayley graph.
So they gave an explicit
construction of a Cayley graph,
with the group being the
projective special linear
group--
PSL 2 q.
So, some group-- and this
group actually comes up a lot.
It's a group with lots of nice
pseudo-randomness properties.
And to verify that,
the corresponding graph
has the desired
eigenvalue properties,
they had to invoke
some deep results
from number theory
that were related
to Ramanujan conjectures.
So that's why they called
these graphs Ramanujan graphs.
And that name stuck.
So these papers, they
proved that these graphs
exist for some special values
of d-- namely, when d minus 1
is a prime.
There was a later
generalization in the '90s,
by Morgenstern, generalizing
such constructions
showing that you can also take
d minus 1 to be a prime power.
And really, that's
pretty much it.
For all the other
values of d, it
is open whether there exists
infinitely many d-regular
Ramanujan graphs.
In particular, for d equal
to 7, it is still open.
Do there exist infinitely many
semi-regular Ramanujan graphs?
No.
What about a random graph?
If I take a random
graph, what is
the size of its second
largest eigenvalue?
And there is a difficult
theorem of Friedman--
I say difficult,
because the paper itself
is more than 100 pages long--
that if you take a fixed
d, then a random end
vertex d-regular graph.
So what does this mean?
So the easiest way to explain
the random d-regular graph
is that you look at the set of
all possible d-regular graphs
on a fixed number of
vertices and you pick one
uniformly at random.
So random-- such graph
is almost Ramanujan,
in the following sense--
that the second largest
eigenvalue in absolute value
is, at most, 2 root d minus
1 plus some small arrow
little 1, where the
little 1 goes to 0
as n goes to infinity.
So in other words, this
constant cannot be improved,
but this result doesn't tell
you that any of these graphs are
Ramanujan.
Experimental evidence
suggests that if you
take, for fixed value of d--
let's say d equals to
7 or d equals to 3--
if you take a random
d-regular graph,
then a specific percentage of
those graphs are Ramanujan.
So the second largest
eigenvalue has
some empirical
distribution, at least
from computer experiments,
where some specific fraction--
I don't remember
exactly, but let's
say 40% of three
regular graphs--
is expected in the
limit to be Ramanujan.
So that appears to
be quite difficult.
We have no idea how to even
approach such conjectures.
There were some exciting
recent breakthroughs
in the past few years concerning
a variant, a somewhat weakening
of this problem--
a bipartite analogue
of Ramanujan graphs.
Now, in a bipartite graph--
so all bipartite graphs
have the property
that its eigenvalues,
its spectrum,
is symmetric around 0.
Its smallest
eigenvalue is minus d.
So if you plot all
the eigenvalues,
it's symmetric around 0.
This is not a hard fact to see--
I encourage you
to think about it.
And that's because, if
you have an eigenvector--
so it lifts
somewhere on the left
and somewhere on the right--
I can form another
eigenvector, which
is obtained by flipping
the signs on one part.
If the first eigenvector
has eigenvalue lambda,
then the second one has
eigenvalue minus lambda.
So the eigenvalues come
in symmetric pairs.
So by definition, a
bipartite Ramanujan graph
is one where it's
a bipartite graph
and I only require that the
second largest eigenvalue
is less than 2 root d minus 1.
Everything's symmetric
around the origin.
So this is by definition.
If you start with
a Ramanujan graph,
I can use it to create a
bipartite Ramanujan graph,
because if I look
at this 2 lift--
so where there's
this construction--
this means if I start with
some graph, G-- so for example,
if G is this graph
here, what I want to do
is take two copies
of this graph,
think about having them
on two sheets of paper,
one on top of the other.
And I draw all the
edges criss-crossed.
So that's G cross K 2.
This is G.
You should convince
yourself that if G
has eigenvalues lambda then
G cross K 2 has eigenvalues.
The original spectrum,
as well, it's
symmetric-- so it's negation.
So if G is Ramanujan,
then G cross
K 2 is a bipartite
Ramanujan graph.
So it's a weaker concept--
if you have Ramanujan graphs,
then you have bipartite
Ramanujan graphs-- but not
in reverse.
But, still a problem
of do there exist
d-regular bipartite Ramanujan
graphs is still interesting.
It's a somewhat weaker problem,
but it's still interesting.
And there was a
major breakthrough
a few years ago by Marcus
Spielman and Srivastava,
showing that for
all fixed d, there
exist infinitely many d-regular
bipartite Ramanujan graphs.
And unlike the earlier
work of Lubotzky, Phillips,
and Sarnak--
which, the earlier work was
an explicit construction
of a Cayley graph--
this construction here is a
probabilistic construction.
It uses some very
nice tools that they
called interlacing families.
So it showed,
probabilistically, using
a very clever
randomized construction,
that these graphs exist.
So it's not just take a usual
d-regular random bipartite
graph, but there's some clever
constructions of randomness.
And this is more
or less the state
of knowledge regarding the
existence of Ramanujan graphs.
Again, the big open problem
is that there exists
d-regular Ramanujan graphs.
For every d, there
are infinitely many
such Ramanujan graphs.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in the
conception of G cross K 2,
lambda 1 is equal to d?
Or is equal to
original [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: Right,
so the question
is, if you start with
a d-regular graph
and take this construction,
the spectrum has 1 d
and it also has a minus d.
If your graph is
bipartite, its spectrum
is symmetric around the origin.
So you always have
d and minus d.
So a bipartite graph
can never be Ramanujan.
But the definition of a
bipartite Ramanujan graph
is just that I only require that
the remaining eigenvalues sit
in that interval.
I'm OK with having minus d here.
So that's by definition of
a bipartite Ramanujan graph.
Any more questions?
All right, so combining
a Alon-Boppana bound
and both the existence
of Ramanujan graphs
and also Friedman's
difficult result
that random graph
is almost Ramanujan,
we see that this
2 root d minus 1--
that number there is optimal.
So that's the extent in
which a d-regular graph
can be pseudo-random.
Now, the rest of
this lecture, I want
to move onto a somewhat
different topic,
but still concerning sparse
pseudo-random graphs.
Basically, I want to tell you
what I did for my PhD thesis.
So, so far we've been talking
about pseudo-random graphs,
but let's combine it with the
topic in the previous chapter--
namely, similarities
regularity lemma.
And we can ask, can we
apply the regularity method
to sparse graphs?
So when we talk about
similarities regularity,
I kept emphasizing that it's
really about dense graphs,
because there are these
error terms which are little
and squared.
And if your graph
is already sparse,
that error term
eats up everything.
So for sparse graphs, you
need to be extra careful.
So I want to explore the
idea of a sparse regularity.
And here, sparse
just means not dense.
So sparse means x
density, little 1.
So, the opposite of dense.
We saw the triangle
removal [INAUDIBLE]..
So, let me remind
you the statement.
It says that for every epsilon,
there exists some delta, such
that if G has a small
number of triangles,
then G can be made
triangle-free by removing
a small number of edges.
I would like to state a sparse
version of this theorem that
works for graphs where I'm
looking at sub constant x
densities.
So roughly, this is
how it's going to go.
I'm going to put in
these extra p factors.
And you should think
of p as some quantity
that goes to 0 with n.
So, think of p as
the general scale.
So that's the x density
scale we're thinking of.
I would like to
say that if G has
less than that many
triangles, then
G can be made free by deleting
a small number of edges.
But what does small mean here?
Small should be relative
to the scale of x
densities you're looking at.
So in this case, we should add
an extra factor of p over here.
So that's the kind of
statement I would like,
but of course, this is
too good to be true,
because we haven't
really modified anything.
If you read the statement,
it's just completely false.
So I would like adding some
conditions, some hypotheses,
that would make such
a statement true.
And hypothesis is going to
be roughly along those lines.
So I'm going to call this a
meta-theorem, because I won't
state the hypothesis precisely.
But roughly, it will
be along the lines
that, if gamma is
some, say, sufficiently
pseudo-random graph and
vertices and x density, p, and G
is a subgraph of
gamma, then I want
to say that G has this triangle
removal property, relatively
inside gamma.
And this is true.
Well, it is true
if you're putting
the appropriate, sufficiently
pseudo-random condition.
So I'm leaving here--
I'll tell you more later
what this should be.
So this is a kind of
statement that I would like.
So a sparse extension of
the triangle removal lemma
says that, if you have a
sufficiently pseudo-random
host, or you think of this
gamma as a host graph,
then inside that host, relative
to the density of this host,
everything should
behave nicely, as you
would expect in the dense case.
The dense case is also a
special case of the sparse case,
because if we took gamma
to be the complete graph--
which is also pseudo-random,
it's everything--
it's uniform-- then
this is also true.
And that's triangle removal
among the dense case,
but we want this
sparse extension.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Where does the
c come into [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: Where
does p come in to--
so p here is the edge
density of gamma.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah.
So again, I'm not really
stating this so precisely,
but you should think
of p as something
that could decay with n--
not too quickly, but decay
at n to the minus some
small constant.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Delta here
doesn't depend on gamma?
YUFEI ZHAO: Correct.
So the question is, what
does delta depend on?
So here, delta depends
on only epsilon.
And in fact, what
we would like--
and this will indeed
be basically true--
is that delta is more
or less the same delta
from the original
triangle removal lemma.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If G is
any graph, what's
stopping you from
making it a subgraph
of some large [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the question
is, if G is some arbitrary
graph, what's to
stop you from making
it a subgraph of a large
pseudo-random graph?
And there's a great question.
If I give you a
graph, G, can you
test whether G satisfies
the hypothesis?
Because the conclusion
doesn't depend on gamma.
The conclusion is only
on G, but the hypothesis
requires us to gamma.
And so my two answers
to that is, one,
you cannot always
embed it in the gamma.
I guess the easier
answer is the conclusion
is false with other hypothesis.
So you cannot always
embed it in such a gamma.
But it is somewhat
difficult to test.
I don't know a good way
to test whether a given
G lies in such a gamma.
I will motivate this
theorem in a second--
why we care about
results of this form.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Don't all sufficiently
large pseudo-random graphs--
say, with respect to the
number of vertices of G--
contain copies of every G?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
question is, if you
start with a sufficiently
large pseudo-random gamma,
does it contain every copy of G?
And the answer is no, because G
has the same number of vertices
as gamma.
A sufficiently
pseudo-random-- again,
I haven't told you what
sufficiently pseudo-random even
means yet.
But you should think of it as
controlling small patterns.
But here, G is a
much larger graph.
It's the same size,
it's just maybe,
let's say, half of the edges.
So what you should think about
is starting with gamma being,
let's say, a random graph.
And I delete
adversarially, let's say,
half of the edges of gamma.
And you get G.
So let me go on.
And please ask more questions.
I won't really prove
anything today,
but it's really
meant to give you
an idea of what this
line of work is about.
And I also want to motivate
it by explaining why we care
about these kind of theorems.
So first observation
is that it is not
true with all the hypothesis--
hopefully all of you
see this as obviously
too good to be true.
But will also see some
specific examples.
Here's a specific example.
So this is not true
without this gamma.
So for example, you
can have this graph, G.
And we already saw
this construction that
came from Behren's construction,
where you have n vertices
and n to the 2 minus little 1
edges, where every edge belongs
to exactly one triangle.
If you plug in this
graph into this theorem,
with all the yellow stuff--
if you add in this p--
you see it's false.
You just cannot remove--
anyway.
In what context can we expect
such a sparse triangle removal
lemma to be true?
One setting for
which it is true--
and this was a result that was
proved about 10 years ago--
is that if your gamma
is a truly random graph.
So this is true
for a random gamma
if p is sufficiently large
and roughly it's at least--
so there's some constant
such that if p is at least c
over [INAUDIBLE],,
then it is true.
So this is the result
of Conlon and Gowers.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this random
in the Erdos-Rényi sense?
YUFEI ZHAO: So this is random
in the Erdos-Rényi sense.
So, Erdos-Rényi random graph.
But this is not the
main motivating reason
why I would like to talk
about this technique.
The main motivating example
is the Green-Tao theorem.
So I remind you that
the Green-Tao theorem
says that the primes contain
arbitrarily long arithmetic
progressions.
So the Green-Tao theorem
is, in some sense,
an extension of
Szemeredi's theorem,
but a sparse extension.
Szemeredi's theorem
tells you that if you
have a positive density
subset of the integers, then
it contains long
arithmetic progressions.
But here, the primes--
we know from prime
number theorem
that the density of
the primes up to n
decays, like 1 over log n.
So it's a sparse
set, but we would
like to know that it has
all of these patterns.
It turns out the primes are,
in some sense, pseudo-random.
But that's a difficult
result to prove.
And that was proved after
Green-Tao proved their initial
theorem--
so, by later works of Green
and Tao and also Ziegler.
But the original strategy--
and also the later strategy for
the stronger result, as well.
But the strategy for the
Green-Tao theorem is this--
you start with the primes
and you embed the primes
in a somewhat larger set.
You start with the
primes and you embed it
in a somewhat larger set,
which we'll call, informally,
pseudoprimes.
And these m, roughly
speaking, numbers
with no small prime divisors.
Because these numbers
are somewhat smoother
compared to the
primes, they're easier
to analyze by analytic
number theory methods,
especially coming
from sieve theory.
And it is easier, although
still highly nontrivial,
to show that these pseudoprimes
are, in some sense,
pseudo-random.
And that's the kind
of pseudo-random host
that corresponds with
the gamma over there.
So the Green-Tao strategy
is to start with the primes,
build a slightly larger
set so that the prime sit
inside the pseudoprimes in
a relatively dense manner.
So it has high relative density.
And then, if you had this
kind of strategy for a sparse
triangle removal lemma--
but imagine you also had it
for various other extensions
of sparse hypergraph removal
lemma, which allows you
to prove Szemeredi's theorem.
And now you can use
it in that setting.
Then you can prove Szemeredi's
theorem in the primes.
That's the theorem and
that's the approach.
And that's one of the
reasons, at least for me,
why something like a sparse
triangle removal lemma
plays a central role in
these kind of problems.
So I want to say
more about how you
might go about proving
this type of result
and also what pseudo-random
graph means over here.
So, remember the strategy for
proving the triangle removal
lemma.
And of course, all of you guys
are working on this problem set
and so the method of
regularity hopefully
should be very familiar to
you by the end of this week.
But let me remind you that
there are three main steps, one
being to partition your graph
using the regularity lemma.
The second one, to clean.
And the third one, the count.
And I want to explain where the
sparse regularity method fails.
So you can try to do
everything the same and then--
so what happens if you try
to do all these things?
So first, let's talk about
sparse regularity lemma.
So let me remind
you-- previously,
we said that a pair of
vertices is epsilon regular
if, for every subset
U of A and W of B--
neither too small.
So if neither are
too small, one has
that the number of
edges between U and W
differs from what
you would expect.
So the x density between U and
W is close to what you expect,
which is the ordinal edge
density between A and B.
So they differ by no
more than epsilon.
So this should be a
familiar definition.
What we would like
is to modify it
to work for the sparse setting.
And for that, I'm going to
add in an extra p factor.
So I'm going to say
epsilon, p regular.
Well, this condition here--
now, oh, the densities
are on the scale of p.
Which goes to 0 as
n goes to infinity.
So in what does the
property compare them?
I should add an
extra factor of p
to put everything
on the right scale.
Otherwise, this is too weak.
And given this
definition here, we
can say that a
partition of vertices
is epsilon regular if all part
but at most epsilon fraction
pairs is epsilon regular--
so an equitable partition.
And I would modify it
to the sparse setting
by changing the appropriate
notion of regular
to the sparse version, where
I'm looking at scales of p.
I still require at
most epsilon fraction--
that stays the same.
That's not affected
by the density scale.
Previously, we had the
irregularity lemma,
which said that
for every epsilon,
there exists some M such
that every graph has
an epsilon regular partition
into at most M parts.
And the sparse version
would say that if your graph
has x density at most p--
and here, all of these
constants are negotiable.
So when I say p, I really
could mean 100 times p.
You just change these constants.
So if it's most p, then it has
an epsilon, p regular partition
into at most m parts.
Here, m depends only on epsilon.
So previously, I wrote down the
sparse triangle removal lemma.
And I wrote down the
statement and it was false--
with all the additional
hypotheses, it was false.
It turns out that this
is actually true--
the version of the
sparse regularity lemma,
which sounds almost too
good to be true, initially.
We are adding in a
whole lot of sparsity
and sparsity seems to be
more difficult to deal with.
And the reason why I
think sparsity is harder
to deal with is
that, in some sense,
there are a lot
more sparse graphs
than there are dense graphs.
So let me pause for a
second and explain that.
It is not true
that, in some sense,
there are more sparse graphs.
Because if you just count--
once you have sparser things,
there are fewer of them.
But I mean in terms of
the actual complexity
of the structures
that can come up.
When you have sparser
objects, there's
a lot more that can happen.
In dense objects,
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
tells us, in some sense,
that the amount of complexity
in the graph is bounded.
But that's not the
case for sparse graphs.
In any case, we
still have some kind
of sparse regularity lemma.
And this version
here, as written,
is literally true if you have
the appropriate definitions--
and more or less, we have
those definitions up there.
But I want to say
that it's misleading.
This is true, but misleading.
And the reason why
it is misleading
is that, in a sparse
graph, you can
have lots of
intricate structures
that are hidden in
your irregular parts.
It could be that most edges are
inside irregular pairs, which
would make the irregularity
lemma a somewhat
useless statement, because
when you do the cleaning step,
you delete all of your edges.
And you don't want that.
But in any case, it is true--
and I'll comment on
the proof in a second.
But the way I want you to think
about the sparse regularity
lemma is that it
should work when--
so before jumping to
that, a specific example
where this happens
is, for example,
if your graph G is a click on a
sublinear fraction of vertices.
Somehow, you might
care about that click.
So that's a pretty important
object in the graph.
But when you do the sparse
regularity partition,
it could be that the
entire click is hidden
inside an irregular part.
And you just don't see it--
that information gets lost.
The proper way to think about
the sparse regularity lemma
is to think about
graphs, G, that satisfy
some additional hypotheses.
So in practice, g is assumed to
satisfy some upper regularity
condition.
And an example of
such an hypothesis
is something called
no dense spots,
meaning that it doesn't have
a really dense component,
like in the case of a click on
a very small number of vertices.
So no dense spots--
one definition could be
that there exists some eta--
and here, just as in
quasi-random graphs,
I'm thinking of
sequences going to 0.
So there exists
eta sequence going
to 0 and a constant,
c, such that for all
set x in the graph--
let's say X and Y. If X and Y
have size at least eta fraction
of V, then the density
between X and Y
is bounded by at most
a constant factor,
compared to the overall density,
p, that we're looking at.
So in other words, no
small piece of the graph
has too many edges.
And with that notion
of the no dense spots,
we can now prove the
sparse regularity lemma
under that additional
hypothesis.
And basically, the
proof is the same
as the usual
semi-regularity lemma proof
that we saw a few weeks ago.
So if you have proof
of sparse regularity
with no dense spots--
hypothesis.
OK, so I claim this as the
same proof as Szemeredi's
irregularity lemma.
And the reason is that in the
energy increment argument,
you do everything the same.
You do partitioning
if it's not regular.
You refine and you keep going.
In the energy
increment argument,
one key property we
used was that the energy
was bounded between 0 and 1.
And every time, you went
up by epsilon to the fifth.
And now the energy
increment argument--
that each step,
the energy goes up
by something which
is like epsilon,
let's say, to the
fifth and p squared.
The energy is some kind
of mean square density,
so this p squared
should play a role.
So if you only knew that,
then the number of iterations
might depend on p--
it might depend on n.
So, not a constant-- and
that would be an issue.
However, if you have
no dense spots--
so, because no dense spots--
the final energy, I claim,
is, at most, something
like C squared p squared.
Maybe some small error,
because of all the epsilons
flowing around, but
that's the final energy.
So you still have a
bounded number of steps.
So the bound only
depends on epsilon.
So the entire proof
runs through just fine.
OK, so having the
right hypothesis helps.
But then I said, the
more general version
without the hypothesis
is still true.
So how come that is the case?
Because if you do this proof,
you run into the issue--
you cannot control the
number of iterations.
So here's a trick introduced
by Alex Scott, who came up
with that version there.
So this is a nice trick, which
is that, instead of using
x squared--
the function as energy--
let's consider a somewhat
different function.
So the function I want to use
is fe of x which is initially
quadratic-- so,
initially x squared--
but up to a specific point.
Let's say 2.
And then after this
point, I make it linear.
So that's the function
I'm going to take.
Now, this function has a
couple of nice properties.
One is that you also have this
boosting, this energy increment
step, because for all
random variables, x--
so x is a non-negative
random variable.
So think of this as edge
densities between parts
on the refinement.
If the mean of x is,
at most, 1, then,
if you look at this
energy, it increases
if x has a large variance.
Previously, when we used fe
as square, this was true.
So this is true
with equal to 1--
in fact, that's the
definition of variance.
But this inequality is also
true for this function, fe--
so that when you do the
irregularity breaking,
if you have irregular
parts, then you
have some variance in
the edge densities.
So you would get
an energy boost.
But the other thing
is that we are
no longer worried about
the final energy being
much higher than the individual
potential contributions.
Because, if you end up having
lots of high density pieces,
they would contribute a lot.
So, in other words,
the expectation
for the second thing is
that the expectation of fe
is upper-bounded by, let's say,
4 times the expectation of x.
And so this inequality there
would cap the number of steps
you would have to do.
You would never actually end
up having too many iterations.
So this is a discussion of
the sparse regularity lemma.
And the main message here
is that the regularity lemma
itself is not so difficult--
that's largely the same as
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
And so that's actually not
the most difficult part
of sparse triangle
removal lemma.
The difficulty lies in the other
step in the regularity method--
namely, the counting step.
And we already alluded
to this in the past.
The point is that there
is no counting lemma
for sparse regular graphs.
And we already saw
an example where,
if you start with a
random graph which
has a small number
of triangles and I
delete a small number
of edges corresponding
to those triangles--
one, I do not affect
its quasi-randomness.
But two, there's no
triangles anymore,
so there's no triangle
counting lemma.
And that's a serious obstacle,
because you need this counting
step.
So what I would
like to explain next
is how you can salvage that
and use this hypothesis here
written in yellow to obtain a
counting lemma so that you can
complete this
regularity method that
would allow you to prove the
sparse triangle removal lemma.
And a similar kind of
technique can allow you
to do the Green-Tao theorem.
So let's take a quick break.
OK, any questions so far.
So let's talk about
the counting lemma.
So, the first case of the
counting lemma we considered
was the triangle counting lemma.
So remember what it says.
If you have 3 vertex sets--
V1, V2, V3-- such that,
between each pair,
it is epsilon regular.
And edge density--
that's for simplicity's
sake-- they all have
the same edge density.
Actually, they can be different.
So d sub ij-- so possibly
different edge densities.
But I have the set-up.
And then the triangle
counting lemma
tells us that the
number of triangles
with one vertex in
each part is basically
what you would expect
in the random case--
namely, multiplying
these three edge
densities together,
plus a small error,
and then multiplying the
vertex sets' sizes together.
So what we would
like is a statement
that says that if you
have epsilon p regular
and x densities now
at scale p, then
we would want the
same thing to be true.
Here, I should add
an extra p cubed,
because that's the densities
we're working with.
And I want some error here--
OK, I can even let you
take some other epsilon.
But small changes are OK.
So that's the kind of
statement we want--
and this is false.
So this is completely false.
And the example
that I said earlier
was one of these examples
where you have a random graph.
So this initial
version is false,
because if you take a G and
p, with p somewhat less than 1
over root n, and then remove
an edge from each triangle--
or just remove all
the triangles--
then you have a graph which
is still fairly pseudo-random,
but it has no triangles.
So you cannot have
a counting lemma.
So there's another example
which, in some sense,
is even better than
this random example.
And it's a somewhat
mysterious example
due to a law that gives
you a pseudo-random gamma.
So it's, in some sense, an
optimally pseudo-random gamma,
such that it is d-regular with
d on the order of n to the 3/2s.
And it's an nd lambda
graph, where lambda
is on the order of root d.
Because here, d
is not a constant.
But even in this case,
roughly speaking,
this is as pseudo-random
as you can expect.
So the second eigenvalue
is roughly square root
of the degree.
And yet, this graph
is triangle free.
So you have some graph which,
for all the other kinds
of pseudo-randomness
is very nice.
So it has all the nice
pseudo-randomness properties,
yet it is still triangle free.
It's sparse.
So the triangle
counting lemma is not
true without
additional hypotheses.
So I would like to add in some
hypotheses to make it true.
And I would like a theorem.
So again, I'm going to put
as a meta-theorem, which
says that if you assume that G
is a subgraph of a sufficiently
pseudo-random gamma and
gamma has edge density p,
then the conclusion is true.
And this is indeed the case.
And I would like to tell
you what is the sufficiently
pseudo-random--
what does that hypothesis mean?
So that at least you have
some complete theorem to take.
There are several
versions of this theorem,
so let me give you one
which I really like,
because it has a fairly
clean hypothesis.
And the version is that the
pseudo-randomness condition--
so here it is.
So, a sufficient
pseudo-randomness hypothesis
on gamma, which is that gamma
has the correct number--
"correct" in quotes, because
this is somewhat normative.
So what I'm really
saying is it has,
compared to a random case,
what you would expect.
Densities of all
subgraphs of K--
2, 2, 2.
Having correct density of
H means having H density.
1 plus little 1 times p, raised
to the number of edges of H,
which is what you would
expect in a random case.
So you should think
of there, again,
not being just one graph,
but a sequence of graphs.
You can also equivalently
write it down
in terms of deltas and epsilons
having error parameters.
But I like to think of it
having a sequence of graphs,
just as in what we did
for quasi-random graphs.
If your gamma has this
pseudo-randomness condition,
which is we're in
this sparse setting.
So if you try to
compare this to what
we did for quasi-random
graphs, you might get confused.
Because there, having
the correct C4 count
already implies everything.
This condition, it
actually does already
include having the
correct C4 count.
So K 2, 2, 2 is this
graph over here.
And I'm saying that if it
has the correct density of H,
whenever H is a
subgraph, of K 2, 2, 2--
then it has a correct density.
So in particular, it already
has a C4 count, but I want more.
And it turns out this
is genuinely more,
because in a sparse setting,
having the correct C4
count is not equivalent to other
notions of pseudo-randomness.
So this is a hypothesis.
So if I start with a
sequence of gammas,
I have the correct
counts of K 2, 2, 2s
as well as subgraphs
of K 2, 2, 2s.
Then I claim that that
pseudo-random host is good
enough to have a
counting lemma--
at least for triangles.
Any questions?
Now, you might want to ask for
some intuitions about where
this condition comes from.
The proof itself
takes a few pages.
I won't try to do it here.
I might try to give you some
intuition how the proof might
go and also what
are the difficulties
you might run into when you
try to execute this proof.
But, at least how
I think of it is
that this K 2, 2, 2 condition
plays a role similar to how
previously, in dense
quasi-random graphs,
we had this somewhat
magical looking
C4 condition,
which can be viewed
as a doubled version of an edge.
So actually, the technical
name is called a blow-up.
It's a blow-up of an edge.
Whereas the K 2, 2, 2 condition
is a 2 blow-up of a triangle.
And this 2 blow-up hypothesis is
some kind of a graph theoretic
analogue of controlling
second moment.
Just as knowing the variance
of a random variable--
knowing its second moment--
helps you to control
the concentration
of that random variable, showing
that it's fairly concentrated.
And it turns out that having
this graphical second moment
in this sense also allows you
to control its properties so
that you can have nice tools,
like the counting lemma.
So let me explain some
of the difficulties.
If you try to run the original
proof of the triangle removal
lemma for the sparse
setting, what happens?
So if you start with a vertex--
so remember how the proof of
triangle removal lemma went.
You start with this set-up
and you pick a typical vertex.
This typical vertex has lots
of neighbors to the left
and lots of neighbors
to the right.
And here, a lot means
roughly the edge density
times the number of vertices--
and a lot of vertices over here.
And then you say that,
because these are two fairly
large vertex sets, there are
lots of edges between them
by the hypotheses on
epsilon regularity,
between the bottom two sets.
But now, in the
sparse setting, we
have an additional factor of p.
So these two sets
are now quite small.
They're much smaller
than what you
can guarantee from the
definition of epsilon,
p regular.
So you cannot conclude from
them being epsilon regular that
there are enough edges between
these two very small sets.
So the strategy of proving
the triangle removal lemma
breaks down in the
sparse setting.
In general-- not
just for triangles,
but for other H's as well--
we also have this
counting lemma.
So, the sparse counting lemma.
And also the triangle case,
which I stated earlier.
So this is drawing work due
to David Colin, Jacob Fox,
and myself.
Says that there
is a county lemma.
So let me be very informal.
So, that there exists a sparse
counting lemma for counting H,
in this set-up as before.
If gamma has a
pseudo-random property
of containing the correct
density of all subgraphs
of the 2 blow-up of H.
Just as in the triangle,
the 2 blow-up is K 2, 2, 2.
In general, the 2 blow-up
takes a graph, H, and then
doubles every vertex
and puts in four edges
between each pair of vertices.
So that's the 2 blow-up of H.
If your gamma has pseudo-random
properties concerning
counting subgraphs
of this 2 blow-up,
then you can obtain a
counting lemma for H itself.
Any questions?
OK, so let's take this counting
lemma for granted for now.
How do we proceed to proving the
sparse triangle removal lemma?
Well, I claim that actually
it's the same proof where
you run the usual simulated
regularity proof of triangle
removal lemma.
But now, with all
of these extra tools
and these extra
hypotheses, you then
would obtain the
sparse triangle removal
lemma, which I stated earlier.
And the hypothesis
that I left out--
the sufficiently pseudo-random
hypothesis on gamma--
is precisely this
hypothesis over here,
as required by the
counting lemma.
And once you have
that, then you can
proceed to prove a relative
version of Roth's theorem--
and also, by extension,
two hyper-graphs--
also a relative version
of Szemeredi's theorem.
So, recall that the Roth's
theorem tells you that if you
have a sufficiently large--
so let me first write
down Roth's theorem.
And then I'll add in the extra
relative things in yellow.
So if I start with A,
the subset of z mod N,
such that A has size--
at least delta n.
So then, Roth's
theorem tells us that A
contains at least one three-term
arithmetic progression.
But actually, you can
boost that theorem.
And you've seen some
examples of this in homework.
And also our proofs also
do this exact same thing.
If you look at any of the
proofs that we've seen so far,
it tells us that A not only
contains one single 3Ap,
but it contains many
3Ap's, where C is
some number that is positive.
So you can obtain
this by the versions
we've seen before, either
by looking at a proof--
problem is in the the
proof gift stack--
or by using the black box
version of Roth's theorem.
And then there's a super
saturation argument,
which is similar to things
you've done in the homework.
What we would like is
a relative version.
And a relative version will
say that if you have a set, S,
which is sufficiently
pseudo-random.
And S has density, p.
Here, [INAUDIBLE].
And now A is a subset of S.
And A has size at least delta,
that of S. Then, A contains
still lots of 3Ap's, but I
need to modify the
quantity, because I
am looking at density, p.
So this statement is
also true if you're
putting the appropriate
hypothesis into sufficiently
pseudo-random.
And what should
those hypotheses be?
So think about the proof
of Roth's theorem--
the one that we've done--
where you set up a graph.
So, you set up this graph.
So, one way to do
this is that you
say that you put in edges
between the three parts--
x, y, and z.
So the vertex sets are
all given by z mod N.
And you put in an edge between
x and y, if 2x plus y lies in S.
Pulling the edge between
x and z-- if x minus z
lies in S and a third
edge between y and z,
if minus y minus 2z
lies in S. So this
is a graph that we constructed
in the proof of Roth's theorem.
And when you construct this
graph, either for S or for A--
as we did before--
then we see that the
triangles in this graph
correspond precisely to
the 3Ap's in the set.
So, looking at the triangle
counting lemma and triangle
removal lemma-- the
sparse versions--
then you can read out what type
of pseudo-randomness conditions
you would like on S--
so, from this graph.
So, we would like
a condition, which
says that this graph here--
which we'll call gamma sub S--
to have the earlier
pseudo-randomness hypotheses.
And you can spell this out.
And let's do that.
Let's actually spell this out.
So what does this mean?
What I mean is S, being
a subset of Z mod N--
we say that it satisfies
what's called a 3-linear forms
condition.
If, for uniformly
chosen random x0,
x1, y0, y1, z0, z1
elements of z mod nz.
Think about this K 2, 2, 2.
So draw a K 2, 2, 2 up there.
So what are the edges
corresponding to the K 2, 2, 2?
So they correspond to the
following expressions--
minus y0 minus 2z0--
minus y1 minus 2z0--
minus y0 minus 2z1--
minus y1 minus 2z1.
So those are the edges
corresponding to the bottom.
Draw C4 across the
bottom two vertex sets.
But then there are
two more columns.
And I'll just write
some examples,
but you can fill in the rest.
OK, so there are at
least 12 expressions.
And what we would like is that,
for random, the probability
that all of these numbers
are contained in S
is within 1 plus little 1
factor of the expectation,
if S were a random set.
In other words, in this
case, it's p raised to 12--
random set of density, p.
And furthermore, the same
holds if any subset of these 12
expressions are erased.
Now, I want you to use your
imagination and think about
what the theorem would look like
for not 3Ap's, but for 4Ap's--
and also for k-Ap's in general.
So there is a relative Szemeredi
theorem, which tells you
that if you start with S--
so here, we fix K. If
you start with this S,
that satisfies the
k-linear forms condition.
And A is a subset of S
that is fairly large.
Then A has k-Ap.
So I'm being
slightly sloppy here,
but that's the spirit
of the theorem--
that you have this
Szemeredi theorem
inside a sparse
pseudo-random set,
as long as the
pseudo-random set satisfies
this k-linear forms condition.
And that k-linear
forms condition
is an extension of this
3-linear forms condition, where
you write down the proof that
we saw for Szemeredi's theorem,
using hyper-graphs.
Write down the
corresponding linear forms--
you expand them out and then
you write down this statement.
So this is basically what
I did for my PhD thesis.
So we can ask, well, what
did Green and Tao do?
So they had the original
theorem back in 2006.
So their theorem, which also was
a relative Szemeredi theorem,
has some additional,
more technical hypotheses
known as correlation conditions,
which I won't get into.
But at the end of the day, they
constructed these pseudoprimes.
And then they verified that
those pseudoprimes satisfied
these required
pseudo-randomness hypotheses--
that those pseudoprimes
satisfied these linear forms
conditions, as well as
their now-extraneous
additional pseudo-randomness
hypotheses.
And then combining this
combinatorial theorem
with that number
adiabatic result.
You put them together, you
obtain the Green-Tao theorem,
which tells you not just that
the primes contain arbitrarily
long arithmetic progressions,
but any positive density
subset of the primes
also contains arbitrarily
long arithmetic progressions.
All of these theorems--
now, if you pass down
to a relatively dense subset,
it still remains true.
Any questions?
So this is the general method.
So the general method is you
have the sparse regularity
method.
And provided that you have
a good counting lemma,
you can transfer the entire
method to the sparse setting.
But getting the counting lemma
is often quite difficult.
And there are still
interesting open problems--
in particular, what kind of
pseudo-randomness hypotheses
do we really need?
Another thing is that
you don't actually
have to go through
regularity yourself.
So there is an additional
method-- which,
unfortunately I don't
have time to discuss--
called transference,
where the story I've told
you is that you
look at the proof
of Roth's theorem, the proof
of Szemeredi's theorem.
And you transfer the
methods of those proofs
to the sparse setting.
And you can do that.
But it turns out, you can
do something even better--
is that you can
transfer the results.
And this is what
happens in Green-Tao.
If you look at Szemeredi's
theorem as a black-box theorem
and you're happy
with its statement,
you can use these
methods to transfer
that result as a black
box without knowing
its proof to the sparse
pseudo-random setting.
And that sounds almost
too good to be true,
but it's worth
seeing how it goes.
And if you want to learn
more about this subject,
there's a survey by Colin Fox
and by myself called "Green-Tao
theorem, an exposition."
So, where you'll find a
self-contained complete proof
of the Green-Tao theorem,
except no modulo--
the proof of Szemeredi's
theorem, which
we've called as a black box.
But you'll see how the
transference method
works there.
And it involves
many of the things
that we've discussed
so far in this course,
including discussions of the
regularity method, the counting
lemma.
And it will contain a proof of
this sparse triangle counting
lemma.
OK, good.
We stop here.